for a hundred years people who wanted to
talk to other people were wired to their
homes they were latched a chained to
their desks and really didn't have much
in the way of freedom that we were in
fact putting people giving people
communications in their vehicles but
even then that's not much better than
being tied to your desk you're still
trapped in your car so we found out from
people like the superintendent of police
in Chicago who told us that he had a
real problem these officers had to be in
communications the only way they could
talk was to be in their cars and yet the
people they were protecting were walking
on the streets he asked us how can I
have my officers connected and still in
mingling with the people and we
discovered this was true of people in
managing airports people managing
businesses real estate people so we
became aware of the fact that real
communications is portable
communications put the device on the
person
I was four years old lived in Winnipeg
Canada where it's very cold in the
winter and very hot in the summer and I
look at these boys with a magnifying
glass and they were burning a piece of
paper by focusing the Rays of the Sun to
this paper through a magnifying glass
and I just have to know how that works
and so I did the obvious thing I took a
soda pop bottle and broken and try to
make a magnifying glass out of it and
that's when I realized now that I had
discovered that I was going to be an
engineer because I want to know how
everything works and I always have
when I was nine years old I invented at
least I think I invented a train that
could travel through a tunnel from one
end of the country to another and what
was unique about this crane was two
things I had learned about friction and
so we had to get rid of friction and so
I thought about why don't we support
this train on a magnetic field because I
knew the two magnets when they are close
together for sub cells apart and the
second thing is if we want to get a rid
of all friction we have to get rid of
the error so this train travelled in a
tunnel that was totally evacuated it was
it a vacuum and macey enough they are
just starting to build trains like that
maybe without the vacuum but with
magnetic levitation so maybe it wasn't
such a dumb idea after all
science has been part of my life from
the time I was four years old just
knowing how things work now having a
curiosity and and my curiosity has been
limitless and that's quite a handicap
because there are times in your life
when you have to specialize but I
literally want to know everything and
only in recent years have I finally
realized that I'm never going to know
everything in fact the older I get and
the more stupid I find out that i am but
science the understanding of how things
work what things are has been crucially
important to me so I start out with
fantasy I've always loved science
fiction I've always known I was going to
be an engineer so I went to a technical
high school so that I could take every
kind of shop at learn how to work with
my hands learn about materials and I
always knew that I was going to go to an
engineering school and get an extern
degree
well science can be interesting science
can be fun and if in fact teachers learn
how to present a science in that way and
learn how to make people curious how to
make it enjoyable you know I think more
people will get involved but it's not
important that everybody become a
scientist everybody doesn't have to be a
mathematician make it interesting enough
so the people that have that interest
that have that challenge do latch on to
the wonderful world that will open up if
they dig into science and mathematics
the teaching of science mathematics of
anything there really is no different
than a game if you make a game dull if
make it uninteresting if you don't have
something that grabs people they won't
get interested and go do something else
so I don't see why teaching should be
any different than teeth then creating
games creating a curriculum a lot to be
the same as creating a game make it
interesting make it fun make it a
challenge all of those things all of the
attributes of player game are the things
that draw people into learning and I
think that's what we ought to do we are
somehow coalesce the concept of teaching
with the concept of game playing and
we're going to find that a lot more of
our youngsters are going to get
interested in learning and specifically
about science mathematics technology
you